what's going on people today we're
breaking down the final ever episode of
Attack on Titan in hopefully around 40
minutes or less along the way I'll be
explaining certain key moments character
motivations small details you might have
missed and just My overall thoughts on
the ending itself just before we dive
into it though I should mention that one
of my upcoming videos is a full updated
recap of the alternate timeline where
vvin got the Colossal Titan so if you
don't want to miss that then remember to
smash that sub button with notific on
all right so the final final episode of
Attack on sidon began with a flashback
to 2,000 years ago when yumia was still
just a slave for the eldian tribe at
that moment in time she had no Titan
powers and no hope of escape and there
are two key reasons why this scene is
important reason number one is that it
gave us a rare insight into yia's
motivations specifically her feelings
about Freedom itself earlier this season
we know that she initially had a pretty
peaceful existence that was brutally
taken away from from her and ever since
then she's had no control over her own
life however as she stared at the pigs
in this scene we see her come to the
realization that although she can't
attain freedom for herself in this
specific moment she at least had the
power to Grant freedom to something else
despite the obvious risk involved Yia
freed these pigs simply because she had
the chance to do it and that's why it's
so interesting that when she had the
chance to be free in this moment and in
this moment on both occasions she chose
to remain as a slave this leads us to
the all important question why is it
that someone who clearly values Freedom
would willingly deny that same freedom
for herself Zeke theorized it it's
because there's something yumia couldn't
let go of and Aaron confirmed that that
thing was the love she had for King
Fritz now this topic is definitely one
of the stranger elements of the series
but in my opinion the anime did a
slightly better job of conveying why it
happened in the first place when we look
at the Manga version we see that yia's
fascination with love it began when she
saw this random couple getting mad
married and from the way the chapter was
drawn to me there was never anything
about this couple that really stood out
however when rewatching her backstory in
the anime it finally became clear to me
that yeah this wasn't just any random
person when you look at the nose facial
hair forehead wrinkles and pretty much
everything this is clearly King fritz or
I guess he was Chief Fritz at the time
you might be wondering though why would
it even matter if this was Fritz and to
answer that question we have to look at
things from yia's perspective on the day
her Village was massacred was the one
who led that operation so from her point
of view this guy is just you know a
cruel and violent person to then witness
that same evil human displaying this
kind of gentleness and affection it
would understandably be a huge shock and
it showed that when love is involved
even a Savage like him can treat people
nicely on top of that the wedding itself
was an example of what happiness looks
like which is something that Yia likely
aspired to have as a slave who had no
happiness no family and no nowhere to go
even if she did somehow Escape King
Fritz's love was the only thing in her
mind that could potentially give her
that happy life that's the sole reason
why she returned to him even after
achieving the power of the Titans since
she thought that by being useful to him
he'd eventually show her the same
affection she saw from him on that day
of course as we all know he never viewed
her as anything more than just his slave
but it was her desire to experience this
affection from Fritz that kept her loyal
to him even after after her own death
we'll talk more about her mindset
towards the end of the video but for now
the main reason why this scene was
significant is that it showed us that
she's always valued freedom from the
beginning and that it's the curse of
love that kept her trapped in PS for
2,000 years also the second reason why
it matters is that this is just a great
example of the butterfly effect given
that immediately after she freed the
pigs the episode abruptly flashes
forward to her standing on aon's
founding Titan for me this contrast
worked incredibly well while since it
was directly showing us how a seemingly
minor decision from 2,000 years ago has
led to this insane series of events
where now all life on Earth is getting
trampled moving on to the alliance after
Rina destroyed the fake Beast Titan in
part three the group now realized that
finding Zeke inside this massive pile of
bones is virtually impossible as a
result the quickest option to stop the
rumbling would be to kill Aaron himself
or at the very least blow his Titan to
pieces and this is where the Colossal
Titan comes in as Arman struggled with
the idea of using his explosive power
against his best friend he thinks to
himself those who can't abandon anything
can't change anything this was a direct
reference to something he previously
said about Irvin in season 1 cuz at the
time the old Commander had he'
effectively sacrificed hundreds of
Scouts in his plan to capture the female
Titan and although not everyone was cool
with that Armen said that to change the
world you have to be willing to
sacrifice things that you care about
given that Armen himself is now
commander of the scouts and given that
he's alive in anan's place this is the
moment where he's kind of stepping into
that type of role and beginning to
accept that this might end with eron not
surviving what I loved about this whole
moment is that throughout the entire
episode in fact every time someone
alluded to the possibility of Aaron
dying mik's reaction was always
consistent like it was very clear that
she was never on board with taking
things that far which is one example of
the parallels between Mikasa and Yia at
the end of the day these are two
characters who are both in love with
genocidal maniacs and who would usually
put their lives on the line to defend
that Maniac regardless of the situation
that being said in a perfect world yir
would have had the courage to let King
Fritz die on the day he was nearly
assassinated but instead her love for
him meant that she didn't have the
strength to let it happen by comparison
Mikasa is in a very similar situation in
that the person she loves is being
targeted by other people and just like
Yia is ultimately her her decision
whether he lives or dies what Yia wanted
to see is someone who would make the
difficult choice that she wasn't able to
and in the process demonstrate that
being in love doesn't necessarily mean
being subservient to that person however
in order to reach this end point Yia
puts pressure on the alliance by
summoning an Army of Ancient Titans as
the name suggests these are Titan
Shifters from the past some of whom you
would have to assume we're in the great
Titan war and there were a few designs
here that I just wanted to highlight
easily the best looking one for me at
least was the RoboCop Warhammer Titan
they ended up getting pummeled by rer
but besides that the draw Titan with the
rectangular Ice slots and the giant deer
Beast Titan they were in my top five uh
but it's just a shame we couldn't see
more of the creatures shown in the
opening for season to I mean I think
that would have been the perfect payoff
although to be fair I don't think Ryan
would stand much chance against a
freaking T-Rex now before we explain
what's going on with Armen a quick word
from today's sponsor War Thunder the
free online game available on
PlayStation Xbox and PC when it comes to
vehicle combat War Thunder offers easily
the most complete experience ever proven
by the selection of over 2,000 tanks
planes helicopters and warships
personally one of my favorite things
about this game when playing it on
Playstation was aerial combat in
particular the hyper realistic damage
models that come with it of course every
vehicle in the game is incredibly
detailed by default but there are still
a wide range of customization options
including skins 3D decorations and these
anime inspired body pillars to play War
Thunder for free on PC or consoles be
sure to click the link in my description
and you'll be able to claim all of these
free bonuses that you can see on screen
and if you're a new player or even an
existing player who hasn't played for 6
months or more you'll be able to claim
all of these free bonuses now pretty
soon after the ancient Titans appeared
Armen gets violated by the aopi Titan
which is a type of animal I think most
of us probably wouldn't know about if it
wasn't for this show and by swallowing
him like this this it was a very
calculated move by yir moments earlier
Armen told the rest of the alliance to
get away as he was planning to blow the
place up and so by kidnapping him like
this it forced the rest of them to stick
around and try and fight to get him back
when it comes to Peak though you have to
respect that she really didn't want the
hassle and early on she tries to avoid a
big battle by just killing Aaron with
dynamite sadly for her she got stopped
by the ghost of Lara Tyber and from that
point onwards the alliance really did
struggle against this on slaugh of
ancient Titans during the chaos we did
get this heartfelt moment where Jean
still acknowledges Riner as a member of
the scouts and to me this was
significant because even in previous
Seasons when they were trying to kill
each other there were a few times where
it was kind of obvious that deep down
Jean secretly did still care about him
now that doesn't mean by itself that he
forgives rer for the things he did but
it does show you that the years they
spent together wasn't just forgotten
after the Warriors betrayed them and I
guess this was him finally admitting
that to his face regardless with the
exception of Mikasa things weren't
looking too good for the alliance until
Falco swoops in to save them with his
flying Titan his ability to fly in this
finale shouldn't have been too much of a
surprise for everyone considering the
dreams he was having in part three but
there were still a few small details
that suddenly became relevant in this
moment for example in episode 19 of the
final season when Aaron is entering the
PA Dimension he sees a vision of Falco's
Titans soaring towards for alter which
is where this final battle is taking
place in hindsight we can now say that
this Vision was a memory from the future
and speaking of future Memories the next
small detail comes straight from episode
one of this season shortly after we were
introduced to Falon for the first time
he wakes up from a dream in which he
says he was flying around with a sword
while there were also Titans nearby that
line about flying around with a sword
was a bonus detail that was specifically
added for the anime but it was never in
the manga and it was directly hinting at
this final battle where you have a bunch
of Titans a bunch of people with swords
and a flying Falon literally carrying
them on his back finally the third
Easter egg that was relevant to this
came in episode two of the final season
where General Calvi made a throwaway
comment about how the marlean Army could
use a Titan with wings moving on with
Falco Annie and Gabby arriving at Fort
Sala the alliance then splits into
separate teams with one team having the
job of saving Armen while the other had
the job of blowing up Aaron's neck by
this point the entire group except
Mikasa had reluctantly accepted that to
stop the rumbling Aaron has to die
otherwise everything they've done up
until now would be for nothing
technically speaking there was also a
third team here consisting of Levi who
was injured and Gabby whose main
superpower is of course her 100%
accuracy as we already know the
captain's main aim in being here was to
fulfill his promise to Irvin by killing
Zeke and the irony of the situation is
that two times in the past Levi could
have easily done it like this isn't a
skill issue for him it's just that on
both occasions he wanted to preserve the
Beast Titan so that someone on the
island could steal his power the problem
now with this third attempt to kill Zeke
is that after he was absorbed by the
source of all living matter his body
became a physical part of the founding
Titan making him undetectable unless he
chooses to reveal himself in a second
we'll talk more about Zeke and his
mental state but first Armen was busy
having a breakdown inside of the PA's
dimension one of the things I thought
was funny about this scene was the huge
contrast between his opinion and the
captain's opinion on who should have
been brought back to life and turned
into the Colossal Titan just a couple
minutes earlier in the episode Levi made
a comment that he had no regrets about
entrusting the future to Armen which may
have been a reference to when he
initially gave Armen the injection and
told him not to make him regret it on
the flip side Armen has said in the past
that it was definitely the wrong choice
and in this scene he Echoes that same
sentiment believing that he hasn't
repaid the second life he's been given
after calming down though he does
eventually realize that he's in the P
Dimension and eventually finds Zeke
quietly building a sand castle this is
what brings us to Zeke's mental state
because from the beginning he always
believed that the existence of ens was
pointless since around the world all
they do is experience suffering or just
cause suffering to others in the form of
titans in his mind everyone would be
better off if subjects of yir were just
never born again and this ideology
formed the entire basis of his
euthanization plan however when Yia
turned her back on him and joined up
with Aaron instead it sent Zeke into
this depressed state where now it seems
like he's given up on the rest of
humanity as well not just eldians from
his New Perspective all life is
effectively meaningless since from the
beginning of time the goal of life has
only been to survive and to multiply the
biggest proof of this is the source of
all living matter itself since although
it can't seem to reproduce it uses other
other living things to do the job on its
behalf an example of what I mean by this
is how even when yumia died the creature
still managed to survive by attaching
itself to her descendants and in turn
the number of Titans kept multiplying
that's why in the present day there are
millions of alens around the world who
in the right circumstances can be used
as its own personal Army and this was
all done in the name of survival Zeke's
point was that being driven by this
instinct to survive and multiply is
meaningless and that it's time to let go
of this natural instinct to survive that
seems to motivate a lot of the things we
do on a day-to-day basis on the flip
side Army's belief is that life is given
meaning by the small trivial moments
that we sometimes enjoy and if you're an
anime only I want you to know that you
were robbed of this flashback of him
feeding this tiny squirrel anyhow within
the P Dimension alen finds this Leaf in
the sand and throughout the episode this
object kept manifesting itself as
different things to different people in
armen's case it appeared as a leaf
because that symbol izes his most
precious childhood memory of embracing
Aaron and Mikasa towards the tree on the
hill conversely physique it appeared as
a baseball since that represents the
games of catch he used to play with Tom
SAA and despite having nothing to do
with survival that game did give meaning
to his life as well as a child all Zeke
wanted was for gisha to show him a
degree of like fatherly attention like
all the other kids but instead all his
dad cared about was turning him into the
Messiah of the ens as a result these
games were the only time a father figure
gave him the quality time that he wanted
and although catch by itself has no
meaning Zeke admits that he would have
been happy playing it forever just by
saying this he's acknowledging armen's
perspective that there's more to life
than just survival and multiplication
and this moment is when a bunch of Dead
characters suddenly reappear in parts
for the most part you can understand why
most of these characters are here like
the three former Warriors obviously have
a connection to Zeke and would be
against the rumbling but for Aaron
Krueger I'm honestly not so sure this is
a man who by his own admission has
killed thousands of ens throughout his
life and the only reason he took things
that far was cuz he believed in the end
it would lead to eldia being restored
his goal and the goal of the other
restorationist was to take back the
founding Titan get revenge on Marley and
bring back the eldian Empire so however
evil the rumbling might be Aaron Jer is
ticking all of those boxes that's why to
me I don't really see why Krueger would
help stop the rumbling at all gisher is
slightly different given that he already
said he didn't support taking things
this far but Krueger he's the guy who
was taking things super far already he
was willingly sacrificing people to
achieve this goal let me know what you
think in the comments down below like I
think all the other people here would
help Arman and Zeke but Krueger is the
one I'm just like you probably shouldn't
be here now one thing that's worth
mentioning is that before this scene we
got a montage of Titans trampling
different parts of the globe and this
was interesting cuz it gave us our first
real look into other foreign countries
besides Marley in the Middle East in
particular we saw London a couple of
Asian cultures including what is
potentially hiizu not to mention they
showed the attack on Titan equivalent of
the African continent by zooming in here
you can see a group of tribes people
watching on as the rumbling approaches
them and scenes like this do help to
humanize the rest of the world for
example it's not like these tribes
people were any kind of threat to the
Island in fact like Historia said most
of these people don't have any idea why
they're being killed as an audience
though because we barely know any people
outside of Mary it can sometimes be
difficult for us to empathize with
characters who you never really see
that's why this Montage was so important
cuz it demonstrates the reality of the
situation that the vast majority of
people in the world are innocent and
they don't really deserve this in the
slightest as a side note one of the best
creative choices of the finale was the
whole black and white scene where only
the mother and baby were colored in and
I can't take any credit for finding this
Easter egg but it does seem like the
mother here who was falling off the
cliff was the same woman that eron saw
back in Marley when she was pregnant I
think I just saw that on Twitter
somewhere so I thought I'd mention it
but yeah it's pretty that's a pretty
amazing detail anyhow back at Fort
Salter the alliance was once again on
the brink of getting wiped out until
berol and the other past Titans agreed
to help stop the rumbling personally I
would have loved if these has shown a
little bit of Personality instead of
just staring blankly and never saying
anything cuz if you're burtal you have
to get at least a few hits on Armen
before listening to what he has to say
regardless in the real world the Titans
rally together to protect the alliance
and this shot of Krueger breaking the
armor Titans back this was great simply
because he used the exact same finishing
move as when he tore apart that Maran
ship on top of that you had Tom saa's
Ram Beast Titan making its first
appearance and just like like how Zeke's
Titan form was inspired by a childhood
toy Tom's Beast Titan form was inspired
by one of his son's stuffed animals a
reasonable explanation for this is that
we know yamir is the one who designs
these Titans in the P Dimension and
considering that she has full access to
the memories of every eldian it's likely
that she selects the design based on
animals that have you know some kind of
emotional significance to that person
obviously this is just my theory or head
Cannon whatever you want to call it um
but I do think it makes a lot of sense
moving on there was a moment where Gabby
and Mikasa combined to free Armen from
inside the aopi Titan while Zeke showed
off his brand new cheeks made from Titan
hardening in this sequence the Beast
Titan was offering himself up as a
sacrifice to stop the rumbling cuz it
was already established that Aaron can't
continue this massacre if he doesn't
maintain contact with the Titan of Royal
Blood having now realized that life
isn't just a pointless game of survival
and multiplication he takes a quick
second to appreciate the weather cuz
after his talk with arm I guess he
learned to appreciate the smaller things
in life that he was taking for granted
that being said his New Perspective
doesn't last for long as Captain Levi
swoops in to decapitate him and it is
ironic how when the moment finally came
of the captain killing Zeke the two of
them were genuinely on the same side
here every time they clashed before
there was obviously huge differences in
what they were trying to achieve and
what they were fighting for but in this
case they share that overarching goal of
stopping Aaron of course for Levi he
gets the added bonus of fulfilling the
promise he made to Irvin and by killing
Zeke all of the wol Titans around the
world immediately come to a stop
technically speaking you can argue this
is a plot hole given that back in season
2 Aaron was able to temporarily control
an army of Titans even after Dino Fritz
was killed and so if we follow that
exact same logic then he should have
been able to continue the rambling at
least for a little bit after Zeke's
death because you know that power of the
founding Titan it lingers for a little
bit longer
however a Counterpoint to this is that I
think we can all agree that if yamir
wants the rumbling to stop then it's
going to stop and by her allowing Zeke
to switch sides which is what she did
she let it happen it clearly shows that
this is how she wants the events to play
out when the Beast Titan died if we're
being fully logical then yeah maybe
Aaron could have kept the Titans
Marching for a bit longer but at the end
of the day yamir's aim is to force
Mikasa into a specific situation and
that situation only occurs when the
rumbling stops here following the Titans
coming to a standstill Dron detonates
the explosives around aon's neck and in
the process unleashes the source of all
living matter just like when Gabby
exposed this thing back in chagan it
rushes forward trying to reconnect with
Aaron and this Frame right here is
easily one of my favorites from the
episode can you imagine trying to
explain this image to someone who's just
started season 1 where would you even
begin with this anyway as the alliance
escapes on Falcon's back Armen detonates
his nuke to to blow away this pile of
bones this moment was especially notable
for two reasons the first being that at
the exact same time it was happening
Historia was giving birth back on the
island in case you've never read the
Manga this scene of her giving birth was
meant to take place before the events of
the final episode so you have to wonder
why was it moved to the finale and
specifically why was it placed right
after Armen blows up the founder there
are several ways we can interpret this
for example one explanation is that it's
a tasteful reminder of how historian's
influence indirectly brought them to
this point four years ago it was because
of her that Aaron first saw visions of
the rumbling and of course he had no
idea whether that future was avoidable
then 2 years later when the island was
given an alternative to the rumbling
Aaron had to reject that plan because it
involved Historia and her future kids
all being turned into Titan Shifters in
his words he didn't want her descendants
to be bred and killed like livestock and
he didn't want her joining this cycle of
kids e in their parents in that sense
the birth of this child represents one
of his main motivations for doing the
rumbling which is a future where
Historia and her kids are free from this
responsibility another interpretation is
that this moment is meant to be a
contrast between life and death cuz when
Armen blew up the founding Titan he
acknowledged there was a chance this
could kill Aaron hence why he was saying
goodbye that being said for plot reasons
he was still alive uh but before we get
to that there was a nice moment of the
Warriors being reunited with their
parents up until now they assumed their
families had to be dead since Liberia
was trampled and it's not like aliens
are allowed to leave so to find their
parents here A Million Miles Away in
Fort Sala it's got to be one of the Hall
of Fame coincidences alongside Armen
sitting right next to Annie in part two
for the GCE family specifically this
reunion was a bit Bittersweet since they
found out that one of their kids is now
a giant bird and the other one got
evaporated back in Shanta so yeah not
the the best news meanwhile off in the
distance Aaron generates a brand new
Titan body which combines with his
original founding titan head
strategically speaking turning into a
colossal was his best option to fight
against Armen cuz we've already seen how
badly his regular Titan form compares to
a shifter of this size at the same time
the source of all living matter only had
one aim which was to survive and to do
that it obviously needs to reconnect
with its host body in fact Gabby even
says right here that the rumbling might
start again if Aaron makes contact with
this giant worm which was an interesting
thing to say considering that when the
rumbling stopped Aaron was already in
contact with the worm and it didn't make
a difference so I think what this shows
us is that without Zeke there is pretty
much nothing that would have restarted
the rumbling but it was still necessary
for the alliance to believe there was a
chance otherwise why would Mikasa kill
him for that reason it was also
necessary for Aaron to keep fighting
against them cuz if he had just
peacefully stayed in side of his titan
head then in all likelihood the alliance
would have left it alone and in in the
worst case scenario they would have
killed the source of all living matter
or they would have tried to in that
sense you can understand how all of this
everything that's going on right now is
basically just theater it's Aaron and
yumia going through the motions all to
manipulate other people into taking
certain actions it's partly why later in
the finale he admits to Armen that he's
a slave to freedom because for the
longest time he's been going through the
motions also that the future he saw
would eventually happen now like I was
saying the source of all living matter
desperately wanted to reconnect with
Aaron but in this case Ryo was standing
between them to deal with him the worm
releases a gas similar to the gas that
Zeke used in Rago and this substance was
meant to turn every eldian in Fort Sala
into a pure Titan the only eldians who
were immune from this were either aans
or Titan Shifters which meant that Gabby
Connie and John were among the victims
honestly this would have been the
perfect set end off for these characters
not that I wanted them to die but if
their Journey had ended here it would
have remained as like a permanent
Goosebumps moment that had lasting
consequences a couple of details I want
to mention is that as they're about to
transform Connie jokingly mentions that
this is all Johan's fault because in
season 1 it was him who influenced
everyone to join the scouts up until
then he'd been pretty dead set on having
a kushy life in the military police but
Marco believed that Jean could be a
leader on the actual Battlefield on the
night they then cremated Marco's corpse
his death had a huge impact on Jean's
decision to join the scouts and by
extension it brought him and Connie to
this moment the second detail about this
scene that might have been easy to miss
is that as the smoke fills up for Sala
Annie's dad was specifically asked if he
hurt his leg if we look into Annie's
backstory she was the one who gave him
this lifelong injury and what's funny is
that moments after he's asked this
question she appears in front of him for
the first time in 9 years unfortunately
the reunion gets interrupted when all of
the Normy aliens get titanized leading
us to one of the best moments in the
entire finale this scene of the Warriors
all crying and screaming as they're
mobbed by Titan versions of their own
parents there was a level of like chaos
and hopelessness here that really did
feel like the end of the world what
follows this is arguably the most
confusing sequence of the episode so
let's break it down step by step to
understand what's going on
firstly if we flash back to when the
alliance were traveling to Oda that time
period is when Aaron individually said
goodbye to each of his friends as you
can see here one of those friends was
Armen but he also separately had
conversations with Connie Jean Rina and
Annie that we never got to see what's
important here is that after each
conversation he erased each of their
memories knowing that once he eventually
dies the memories would likely return
however when it comes to Mikasa it was
impossible to do things this way since
Grandpa aiman confirmed a long time ago
that aimin can't have their memories
erased as a consequence Aaron had to
wait until these final chaotic scenes to
have a moment with her and there's an
interesting reason why he chose this
environment although it's true that he
never spoke to Mikasa when she was
traveling to Oda at the very least it
seems like either Aaron or Yia were
aware of what she was thinking at that
time the reason I say that is cuz when
she was on the boat Mikasa wondered to
herself how her life would be different
if she admitted her feelings for him
during their first trip to Marley on
that trip Aaron was having a moral
crisis inside of his own head and when
he asked her about her feelings for him
it's because in this moment he was
looking for a way out an excuse to not
follow the future he saw if Mikasa had
answered differently and not family
zoned him then this could have been
their life where they abandoned
everything to spend his final four years
in peace now despite the fact that this
didn't end up happening in the real
world the p Dimension offered them a
unique chance to experience it like we
saw with Zeke it is possible to spend
what feels like years in here even
though only a few seconds have passed in
reality and there is evidence to suggest
that this is what happens to Mikasa for
example in this scene where she hugs
Aaron she mentions how they previously
agreed that they wouldn't speak about
the day they ran away because she's an
aen it's not like Aaron could have
altered her mind and you know implanted
some kind of fake conversation clearly
they did actually speak before this
confirms that they've been in pars for
longer than what we see in this episode
with Aaron outright saying that running
away to the mountains was her idea
assuming that's true then they've been
here in the PA's dimension for at least
2 months since this moment with the PA's
Dimension offering Miker a chance to
redo her decision whether they then
spent four entire years in PA is
definitely Up For Debate but at the very
least they were here long enough for her
to be happy about the situation it's
relevant to remember that just minutes
earlier in the real world Mikasa was
super depressed cuz she thought that
Aaron had died and that their final
conversation was him saying how much he
hated her to go from feeling like that
to this where they can spend all this
time together in the P Dimension as an
actual romantic couple this is what
enabled her to get the closure she
needed one great thing about this entire
sequence besides the Colossal fight
which looked amazing one great thing is
the way mik's Consciousness flickered in
between the dream and reality the best
example of this is when Aaron tells her
imp pause to throw the scarf away once
he dies to which she replies in the real
world by saying she can't do it from
mik's point of view the scarf represents
her connection with Aaron and her love
for him and the time they spent together
in pars only solidified that feeling
then when she swoops in to decapitate
him it coincides with his death in the
PA's Dimension as in that reality four
years had gone by and his body was
shutting down due to the curse of yir
during the scene where he dies in the
past Dimension you probably notice that
we've already seen this moment back in
part three in case you may have
forgotten this scene in part three was a
dream that young Aaron had while
sleeping under the tree once he wakes up
from that dream the first thing he says
is what am I doing here followed by him
revealing that he had a really long
dream that he's now forgotten one way of
interpreting this is that Aaron's
Consciousness is stuck in some kind of
endless time Loop in which he constantly
relives his own traumatic life or he
just reincar wanted as a seagull
whichever you prefer I honestly don't
mind anyway switching over to Yia after
2,000 years this is exactly what she
wanted to see by Mikasa refusing to let
go of her love for Aaron but at the same
time killing him for the greater good it
showed that you don't have to blindly
obey someone just because you're in love
with them what yamia wanted to know is
that you can still love that person even
if you reject what they tell you to do
and mik's action showed her that she's
free to make her own decisions
regardless of what she felt the king
Fritz on top of that with Aaron being
dead the source of all living matter
didn't have a host body to return to and
so it vanishes Up in Smoke although
admittedly this was a lot clearer in the
Manga version where you actually like
see it disappearing but yeah after aon's
death it didn't have anywhere to go and
so it just died I guess off screen
consequently with the source of all
Titan Powers being destroyed and with
yir being freed the power of the Titans
itself disappears from the world that's
why all the Titan shifters and pure
Titans reverted back into their human
form with the only exception to this
being the wall Titans who I guess we can
assume just were never humans in the
first place either that or you have a
bunch of naked people hiding behind all
this smoke I mean why would they be
naked I don't exactly know but the point
is there should be no one there now
before we get into my thoughts on the
ending especially the time skip scenes I
just wanted to highlight a couple things
from Aaron's final conversation with
Armen that like I said took place a day
before this final battle in this finale
he admits that he thought he was doing
the rumbling to protect his friends but
because he isn't The Mastermind that he
might have appeared to be things still
ended up with Sasha and Hani dying also
before he gained y's power he didn't
actually know if any of his friends
would survive the war this led to him
admitting that his primary motivation
was to destroy everything so we could
see this sight of an uninhabited World
by the way just to clear up any
confusion about this line where he says
I want to do that what he's basically
saying here is that he doesn't
understand why he's always had the
desire to Chase Freedom because when we
look at the first episode 99% of people
inside the walls were happy to live
inside the walls like Aaron was very
much an outlier he's a weirdo most
people were happy with their lives and
it's only people like Aaron and Armen
who were even curious about what lies
beond the wall so when Aaron says I
don't know why I wanted to do this it's
just him saying that he doesn't know why
this is in his name nature he doesn't
know why he's different from most other
people anyway the other thing from his
conversation with Arman that I thought
was worth mentioning was the scene where
he says that his head is just a total
mess because the effect of the founding
Titan power means that from his point of
view there is no past or future
everything just happens at the same time
the side effect of him experiencing the
flow of time in this way is that events
that have happened in the past they have
to happen like he can't change them in
any way and one of those events was the
moment where D Fritz eats his mother in
this scene he admits to Armen that
effectively he was the one who made it
happen because as we saw in in the very
beginning of season 4 there was a moment
there where Dino Fritz could have eaten
beral instead in fact I think in any
other situation there would have been
nothing stopping her she would have just
gone for him she would have eaten him
and she would have become the new
Colossal Titan however that obviously
would have broken the timeline because
everything would have just changed if
that had happened and because of the way
Aaron experiences things he was the one
who influenced dinitz and made her walk
past him and towards his mother and by
doing that it sent the whole events of
this series in motion and gave Aaron the
anger he needed to you know reach this
point in that way it could be said that
Aaron killed his own mother but the
truth is that she probably would have
been eaten anyway if it wasn't Dina
Fritz it would have been another Titan
because you know the whole area was
infested with Titans and her legs were
broken she couldn't have run so there
are just too many factors going on here
for us to say Aon is solely respons
responsible because ultimately she would
have been eaten by someone no matter
what finally the last thing from this
conversation that was worth highlighting
is aon's emotional maturity and I know
that sounds like a joke because he was
breaking down crying and all that stuff
but he is actually being incredibly
emotionally mature when we contrast this
scene where he Reveals His true feelings
and this scene where he is essentially
lying in the scene on the left he tells
Armen that he doesn't want Mikasa to
forget about him for 10 years at least
like that is his true feeling but went
face with Mikasa for the last time
that's not what he tells her he tells
her to throw the scarf away and forget
about him now what this shows is that
Aaron despite often acting like a child
he is emotionally mature because if he
wanted to be selfish he could have told
her the truth that he wants her to keep
thinking about him but he didn't do that
he was doing everything to help Mikasa
kill him and to help Mikasa move on
after he's dead and the ability to not
think of himself and instead think of
the person he loves and how this is all
going to impact her after he's gone that
is a very emotionally mature thing
because he's putting her feelings above
his own also this might be a parallel
with eron's mother because when she was
trapped under that house she told them
to run away but then when they actually
left she was she said don't go so the
two situations do have some similarities
because it's more about protecting the
other person and so it ends up being a
nice parallel anyways after Armen and
Aaron say goodbye to each other the
anime flashes back to the present day
where the power of the Titans has now
officially disappeared as a direct
consequence of this the memories that
were previously removed by Aaron have
now returned to everyone and although we
didn't get to see it he did say goodbye
to each of the people who I already
mentioned it's also heavily implied that
the past Dimension itself has collapsed
which is why we see the vestages of
Irvin Hani and so many other Scouts all
saying goodbye to Levi and we also see
Sasha saying goodbye to Connie and John
following this Mikasa decides to bring
eron's head back to the island to give
him a proper burial although how she
exactly does that I mean Marley has
mostly been trampled so I doubt she
could have taken the train back to
Liberia cuz you know the train tracks
are probably Rubble by now but I don't
know honestly let me know in the
comments if you have a solid idea for
how she got back home uh cuz yeah I
don't really see how she did that also
just like Aaron wanted Armen takes
responsibility for stopping him and the
whole idea behind this was that sort of
like the Tyber family Armen and John and
the rest of them they would become
Heroes of the world who stopped Aaron
from destroying everything this moment
right here was the chance for the ending
to go super dark though because could
you imagine if the Maran soldiers had
just killed all the eldians here
regardless I mean that could have
happened you know like if we're being
realistic secretary Müller was the only
person who had the authority to decide
if the ens lived or died here and you
know he seems like quite a tolerant
person so he let it slide but if that
was someone else I think most Marans in
that situation would have probably just
given the order to Massacre the ens here
especially after you know everything
that had happened but yeah I mean they
got lucky cuz secretary Miller seems to
be a really nice guy and he lets them
live and in doing that they are allowed
to become ambassadors 3 years later for
the rest of the world during that 3year
time skip eldia becomes a highly
militarized country that can't rely on
Titans anymore so their m thing is guns
hence the new flag and you know a lot of
people on the island are just going with
the flow like hitch and it seems like Ki
is back on the island and working with
the JIS which is that is kind of a big
surprise considering how they treated
her towards the end I'm not really sure
what her end game is here exactly um but
if we look in the background it is quite
a multicultural Alliance standing behind
Historia if I had to guess this is
possible that after Aon did the rumbling
and during those three years Historia
and kiomi have somehow managed to get
other nations on their side because
there is a side here it's Elia versus
everyone else and I guess if certain
countries perceive Elder as being more
prepared in the fight that's about to
come then they might decide to join that
alliance with eldia so that their
countries don't get victimized in the
future this Theory becomes even more
believable when we compare the anime
ending to the manga ending because in
the end of the manga within 3 years
there were certain countries that had
pretty much much been rebuilt to the way
they were before U and the best example
of that is this panel right here where
we see on yapan seemingly going to work
we see Falco in a turtleneck without any
problems in the world and we see what
looks like a very builtup modern looking
City now when we contrast this with the
anime ending we don't see anything like
this at best in the outside world all we
see are refugee camps and basically
areas of the planet that need to be
rebuilt we don't see any anything that
looks modern so if we look at the anime
ending only you would believe that the
rest of the world is a lot weaker
compared to the island in fact during
Aaron's final conversation with Armen he
says to him the world outside the walls
drops to the same level of civilization
as parade now he could be referring to
population size but I don't think that's
the case I think what he means is that
the remaining Tech that exists outside
the island it doesn't surpass what
currently exists on parody that would
certainly explain why certain countries
would want to join forces with the
island even after what Aaron did um but
let me know your thoughts on this in the
comments down below now one of the best
moments from this time skip scene that I
think was intentional was when Gabby and
Falon were planting this tree because it
has a secret meaning that relates to
something that Sasha's dad said earlier
in the season back then Sasha's dad said
that the world is a great big Forest
where everyone's fighting for their life
and he implied that Sasha was killed
because she stayed in that forest for
too long in G case he said that it was
the responsibility of adults like him to
make sure that kids like this stay out
of the forest and he was talking about a
metaphorical Forest where people kill
each other and get killed themselves and
now 3 years after that Gabby and Falco
are planting a literal Forest having now
escaped from that metaphorical Forest of
violence thanks to the Titan Powers
disappearing even though it does seem
like a little bit of a reach I do think
that this was intentional um because
it's just too perfect for them to be
planted an actual Forest having gone out
of the metaphorical Forest that he was
talking about I I stand by this I think
this was definitely an intentional
detail a couple other details were
yelling her crying when she saw the
baseball and gloves because it obviously
reminds her of zek and Levi handing out
candy to the refugee kids and you know
when he saw this lollipop it instantly
reminded him of his first trip to Marley
when he saw the clown and I guess in
this scene he did look a bit sad and I'm
pretty sure the reason for this is that
this moment when he first met the clown
it's a time when the scouts were hopeful
they believed that peace was still
possible and that they could reach some
kind of agreement and understanding with
their enemies and so I think that's what
he's reminded of when he looks at this
thing and it's why he kind of like
closes his eyes and looks a little bit
upset because naturally things didn't go
the peaceful way they wanted them to go
at that particular time in their lives
finally back on the island Mikasa was
just chilling by aon's grave which I
imagine she's here quite often and this
was the day that Armen Annie and the
rest of the alliance were arriving back
to Elia for the first time in 3 years
what's interesting is that in that time
despite killing Aaron Mikasa still
hasn't gotten over his death and I think
this actually serves to make what she
did that much more powerful the fact she
was willing to prioritize the rest of
the world over him even though she loves
him this deeply that's the whole reason
why y waited 2,000 years to see it so
what Mikasa still being love with him
shows us is that yes her feelings for
him were always real and her love was so
intense that it still persists even
after she kills him even after 3 years
even after decades she's still in love
with him which only makes her decision
to kill him that much more unbelievable
as the episode then comes to an end a
bird swoops down to fix her scarf which
is something that Aaron himself had
promised to do to fix her scarf forever
honestly this is probably a coincidence
although there is one thing that I would
say Norse mythology has had a huge
impact on this series whether it's the
paths tree aka the world tree whether
it's yir being the first giant whether
it's the nine Realms and the nine Titans
so there's a lot of parallels here and
one thing that happens in Norse
mythology is that Odin who's essentially
you know the most powerful character he
has the ability to see the world through
his Birds I think they're Ravens or
crows he can see the world through their
eyes so based on all the other
connections to Norse mythology that
exist in this series I wouldn't say it's
impossible that eron is either
controlling this bird or seeing the
world through this bird but I also don't
think there's meant to be a 100%
definitive answer now moving on to the
post-credit scenes we got to see
shagan's Evolution over the course of
hundreds if not thousands of years and
if you pause at certain parts there are
major historical events going on and
also conclusion iions to certain
characters for example the first thing
that caught my attention was the arrival
of Armen and the rest of the ambassadors
as they go to visit eron's grave
presumably on the day they arrived or
not long after that and this was the
final time we saw a bunch of characters
I mean Connie Rina Peak Annie they
definitely don't show up in any of the
other post credit scenes Mikasa and
Armen do and Jean potentially does but I
know this is an area of debate but this
was the final appearance of of at a
minimum four major characters but
possibly five following that a lot of
time passes I would think 10 years at
least and Mikus shows up to eron's grave
with a man now the anime doesn't really
make it clear at all who this man is but
I know a lot of you watching would have
seen the manga panel where it does seem
from the hairstyle that if it's any
character we know it would probably be
Jean now while there is no definitive
answer in the anime version I would say
one thing Jean is the only person
possibly in the world who would be okay
with his wife or girlfriend still being
completely obsessed with her dead
ex-boyfriend because ultimately Jean's
been there from the beginning he knows
how Mikasa feels about Aaron and he I
guess he wouldn't expect her to forget
him whereas any other man I'm not sure
if anyone else would be willing to put
up with this this constant eron
Obsession that never goes away so for
that reason just because Ron is a bit um
flexible about the situation I think
yeah it probably is him like if we're
talking about percentages here I would
say like it's 70% going to be him but
honestly if it's a random person like
Historia husband then that's fine too
but I'm just saying what I think is the
most likely scenario decades later we
then see that Shanina is a lot more
built up and they do have cars on the
island now and Mikasa an old version of
Mikasa visits Erin's grave with her
extended family now after looking
zooming in closely on this we see what
is probably mik's adult daughter as and
one grandchild and over here we see a
couple who I assume at least one of
these two people are one of mik's kids
um whether it's the guy or the girl we
have absolutely no clue but they do have
three kids so that's two daughters on
the left and one son on the right and if
this really is Mikasa and Jean as a
couple over here then collectively they
have four grandkids two grandsons and
two granddaughters sometime after this
Mikasa then dies but regardless of what
she died from the fact is that she lived
a long whole life just like Aaron asked
her to do but what she didn't do is
throw the scarf away she held on to it
for her entire life and in death by now
you think she'd at least have like a
second scarf maybe one with a horse on
it or something like that um but no I
guess till the end she really did just
care about Aaron and I guess whatever
her and her new husband had it it just
could never Eclipse how she felt for him
what follows this is a bunch of super
fast moving scenes one of which includes
Armen visiting the grave is an old man
and I'm pretty sure this is Armen like
he's old he's got the blonde hair who
else is this going to be rher no this is
Armen for sure also right after Arman
appears we see these kids racing each
other towards the tree on the hill which
I guess is meant to be like a proper
full circle moment like it's just meant
to be a nice touch as the years then go
by shagan becomes a super industrial
place and it progresses so amazingly
that it actually catches up with our
modern civilization what I never
expected though was that the anime would
show things advancing beyond that point
because in the Manga version the island
basically reached our modern
civilization and then got destroyed but
here it goes so far beyond that like
this is pretty much sci-fi in fact one
of my favorite shows right now besides
anime and stuff one of my favorite shows
is a show called Foundation which is set
like tens of thousands of years in the
future when humans have like moved out
into other solar systems and have pretty
much forgotten that they came from Earth
and this city that I see right here in
Shanina is easily a city that could
exist in that show like things have
progressed this far this sci-fi looking
city was so far in the future that even
though it does get nuked in the end we
can't honestly say that this is because
of the rambling there is an unbelievable
amount of world events that could have
happened in between this point and this
point so many things that would be more
fresh in the mind of the people who were
living in this sci-fi world I honestly
don't think we can say this is because
of the rumbling I think it's just meant
to show that the cycle of of violence it
will continue no matter what because
like Irvin said humans will always have
conflict with each other until there's
only one person left anyhow sometime
after shagan gets nuked into Oblivion
there is this moment where we see a
young boy who's clearly on a journey
with his dog and he it looks like he
knows where he's going like he's not
just wandering aimlessly he knows he's
looking for the tree on the hill where
where Aaron was buried and that made me
wonder a little bit like is there a
story here like why is he seeking out
this tree which is now you know after
all these years it's basically become
the original tree that yir fell into it
looks basically exactly the same and
there are a couple implications of this
for example did the source of all living
matter somehow survive like was there a
piece of it inside of Erin's head
potentially it is interesting to think
about because like Zeke was saying life
always finds a way to adapt and survive
and this tree is Testament to that
somehow the source of all living mastera
or something like that has somehow
managed to restart this whole thing
again what's nice about this situation
though is that unlike Yia who was being
chased by dogs and only ran into the
tree because she needed a place to hide
from being killed this boy is obviously
a lot different he's seeking out the
tree he's looking for it it kind of
makes me think that even if him and the
dog do fall down into there and even if
they were to gain some kind of power it
might not be a destructive power like
the Titans because yumia you know the
whole reason why she became a Titan was
because she wanted to escape death
that's the way Zeke put it she was
trying to escape death and was given an
immortal body that helped her Live
Forever This Boy's intentions I would
imagine are slightly different from that
she I doubt he's trying to escape death
um so the power that he might end up
with it might not be exactly the same
overall I do like this ending it is
quite open-ended but at the same time
you feel like you've been told
everything you need to know like we
don't actually need to see this boy
transforming or anything like that um so
it was a really good way to wrap up the
series in terms of my thoughts on this
series as a whole I mean obviously I
wouldn't have made a 100 videos on
Attack on Titan if I didn't already love
Attack on Titan so even if this ending
was trash which it wasn't it wouldn't
have changed my thoughts on the overall
Series this is a series that was that is
a masterpiece I mean I think from season
one the best thing about this was the
mystery he hid information from us in a
genius way where every time something
was revealed it was shocking but then it
made sense and as we progressed further
and further you know and we learned more
and more about Royal Blood and Marley
and gish's true identity and all these
other things it all fits together like a
perfect puzzle and this final episode
was that last piece and it does feel
incredibly satisfying now that that
piece has been put in its place and the
puzzle is complete however my biggest
criticism of the series is that given
that the ending is so heavily dependent
on mikasa's love for Aaron and Aaron's
love for Mikasa it only makes sense that
it should have been developed more than
it was because I think in retrospect we
can say that it was always obvious that
she liked him but at certain points I
also felt like she thought she was his
mother or his sister she acted a lot
like that on certain occasions so it
wasn't a 100% clear that there was a
romantic connection there and I think
that's the one thing that could have
been improved if there was just a few
more scenes of them having that spark or
chemistry that would have really sold
the ending but it is what it is by the
way if you've made it this far then
don't forget that my updated version of
the alternate timeline will be dropping
relatively soon probably within the next
one or 2 weeks so if you don't want to
miss it then remember to subscribe with
notifications on just before we the
video don't forget to download War
Thunder for free by clicking my link in
the description and you'll get 100,000
silver a 50% booster in your rewards a
body pillow decoration and other parks
for an entire week